[Music]
all right guys i have a video here
that is pretty [ __ ] next level
because it was posted on the subreddit
um next [ __ ] level oh not wall street
bets okay
no i want to talk about tomorrow i know
but i'm not going to be
here i know but that's your fault for
not coming tomorrow i didn't say no
it's fine it's bart's fault actually
portland sorry i didn't know
i didn't know the articles ahead of time
i know anyway so this video here
is about i'll just show you show us
i'll just show you oh we need wd-40 on
these chairs
can you make that out is that bees oh my
god
he's saying those bees aren't biting you
he got honey all over his arm
so is the queen with you okay
you have the queen in your hand is that
why they're with you
he said yeah or they said like when he
said are they not
not biting you and he goes no they know
who their owner
i go he's like hey mind your own [ __ ]
business by the way i like how he's like
on his way yeah to doing whatever he's
got to do
like beekeeper [ __ ] or one of my beasts
for a walk [ __ ]
they're my emotional support bees and
he's really cool he has sunglasses on
he's just cruising
i know man yeah so he says that uh he's
like
no they don't they don't sting me they
know their owner i'm gonna go put them
in a box now
and then when the guy was like do you
have the queen in your hand and because
they are where the queen is and then the
guy says yes i have it in my fist
so then there was just a whole bunch of
people commenting like
what the [ __ ] like i thought like if you
would picture this you would picture a
[ __ ] ton of bees flying around him right
like not like
on him yeah yeah it looks like they're
all a unit
yeah apparently they don't attack you
unless you're like really trying to [ __ ]
with them but you just can't you can
like
take them with you because i saw a bunch
of videos of that like this beekeeper
who
cleans out bees whenever they call her
they have like a bee problem
she never comes in a bee suit she just
comes there picks it up
puts it in a box they all go in there
and then she leaves wow
are you saying we get it wrong about
them bees yeah that they're not [ __ ]
what were the things that you know about
beef oh there's total [ __ ] dicks dude
they stung me when i was a little kid
oh maybe you were the dick damn was i
the dick the whole time
i was the bad guy you were whoa do they
feel our attacking energy is that what
it is
oh you have an attacking energy queen
mandibular
pheromone the queen mandibular pheromone
and it's saying that it's emitted by the
queen
it's the spherical adventure that's what
she's saying queen
because the queen's pheromones are the
most important set of pheromones in the
beehive they listen to
whatever she's emitting and so they're
saying that
if she is safe and she's calm
then there's no reason for the bees to
attack
so someone commented they can smell the
queen through and
they can smell the queen through and on
his fist if she was in danger she'd give
off a scent that screams
help i'm threatened but she's not she's
probably giving off more of a
well this is odd but i am snug and
secure at the moment so
so her drones are just we go on an
adventure
i don't even know what a queen bee looks
like have you guys seen it it's just
fatter
yeah it's faster why do they go around
his arm like that that's where the queen
is they think that it's the new mobile
hive
these are nuts dude they operate as like
one body
he looks like he's like like a evil
villain
in her you can see the other ones are so
much smaller they
constantly just it's a it's a culture of
gang banging
yeah that's all they do for some reason
i thought the cream would be humongous
dude get [ __ ] done just a little bit
just a little bit
i thought it'd be like like i don't know
like like a bumblebee like this or
something
that guy probably does that often huh
like she's like almost twice the size
yeah twice as big okay are queen bees
like
[ __ ] i mean it's probably stupidest
question i've ever asked my whole life
but are they like
does each hive make a new bee eventually
like a new queen bee like if she dies
like
or are they all [ __ ] oh well it was
saying that whenever there's a
new queen or like if the hive gets moved
then they'll just split off the hive
and follow the other queen no there's
two queens where do the queens come from
nina who makes queens yeah words
the queen makes a queen it's calculated
they know how many workers they need
they know whatever
but she makes another queen if she's
gonna die like that kind of [ __ ]
yeah there's like man it's [ __ ] crazy
like there's some of them
i mean i think with the worker bees
right i don't think they
[ __ ] at all they're just made to just
work yeah they're like asexual
that's tight dude imagine all the [ __ ]
we could get done if we were just
asexual drones you already
have one liter i was thinking the same
thing they operate as like one brain
dude
that's [ __ ] weird but we get [ __ ]
done
i know but like well i guess we can make
sweet honey that's cool
we probably put we probably have a dyson
sphere around the sun right now
harnessing its [ __ ]
energy and using it to power our planet
but i like [ __ ] though
you want to lose that no i don't want to
lose it you got him there joe
a lot of what's great about being human
eating food and [ __ ] you're going to
lose all that
yeah bees aren't really bad at [ __ ]
for sure they're awful you want to spend
your time
putting pollen on your ass cheeks yeah
that sounds fun flying flower to flower
that's true that's cute bart yes what a
cute comment bart
i'm a very innocent humor if we could be
human helicopters and just go from
flower to flower
that's kind of cool i don't know if it
gets old though bro really what the
hustle
[ __ ] on the just just one though
[ __ ] stripes off another b those are
the stripes
i'm gonna [ __ ] the stripes off of that
that's so fun aggressive
i don't know about that but you know i
like to hang out with other bees and
[ __ ] you know what i mean
you know what's a useless bee a [ __ ]
hornet
yeah what is it useless dude what's the
difference between a hornet and a wasp
they're just there to [ __ ] people up
they just
sting you multiple times bite you i
forget which one's the one that's
like worse and which one's a yellow
jacket it's a yellow jacket and a wasp
or the other artists
are the closest relatives to yellow
jackets you guys been attacked
man they're [ __ ] hurt dude i got
[ __ ] up on my shins like multiple
times
for real i got something like 13 times
by yellow jacket yellow jackets wasps or
hornets
what does it feel like what would you
equate the paint to pinches but like
stingy pinches like needle pinches yeah
yeah yeah they dig in
oh yeah hanging off my neck and [ __ ] my
mom had to pull a mile i never i never
got stung by any
bee wasp really i don't think i have
either bees just
feel like you got a um like a like a
splinter yeah like but it's burning oh
yeah and you gotta like pull it out
right yeah yeah and it stays in there
bumblebees freak me out the most i think
even though they're
like just sweet little innocent it's
because they're [ __ ] fat
yeah and they're really loud they look
huggable when you see a wasp flying
around you that's not scarier
because they're like yeah they fly like
this you know they're like ready to go
definitely it's scarier but because i
because they're
they look like they could be a bee to me
sometimes like i can't really tell but
bumblebees are like super loud super big
and they're like this black like little
cloud because in the moment you're like
oh [ __ ]
and they're oh it's just a bumblebee so
which one of those is a yellow jacket a
hornet or a wasp
they're like longer this one wasps or
yellow jackets
yeah wannabes they're wannabes man
they're mean
they're very mean i find but maybe i was
the dick too damn i don't want to be a
bee
no [ __ ] way i thought you didn't want to
be a bee no that's bart you want to [ __ ]
the stripes off that beat
as a human he does i don't know man i
if i had to pick any insect i think i'd
be a roly-poly dude
they seemed to fun because you could
just [ __ ] walk around and be like oh
there's haters just roll and then turn
into a ball yeah you have to spend all
your time underneath something
i want to be a ladybug might be fun
because you get to fly and be a
roly-poly
and you're lucky someone's lucky charm
yeah that's true yeah damn that's true
and everybody loves
ladybugs yeah especially bart yeah but
humans
harvest you and sell you rolly pollies
they leave you alone
no i played with them when i was like my
kids kids be killing really all right
let's take it back i'm gonna be
something hey does tycho play with roly
polies
um well in our neighborhood we have a
ton of frogs
you got frogs really nice frogs
i think cause we live next to like uh
remember irrigation or like whatever
place
do they come to your pool yeah there's
like i was in the hot tub and a
frog was just jumping around like what
do you do when
a bunch of frogs around you do you do
you try to like carry them away or what
are you they're not really scared of
people which is crazy like you go up can
you touch them
yeah i've pet one and if i if i pet it
it just goes
just one jump what color are they uh
like maybe like a greenish brown but
they're like this small do you like one
yet
well i was telling you man oh not yet i
i gotta go to costa rica for that
yeah we're in bali there was a there was
a toad this big
room and a frog i thought it was that's
tiny i thought it was a spider i tried
to kill it and it jumped oh i shook the
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] look speaking of spiders just last
night i took this photo i don't wanna
look at it i took this photo oh my god
it's [ __ ] huge can i see
wait what's it for scale how big was it
yeah oh
i don't know like oh i got a picture of
my frog dude no because it was in the
corner
it was in the corner of the garage oh
yeah you want to compete yeah
yeah wait to see this frog
is grabbing the vacuum cleaner and we
just vacuumed it and we're just hoping
he just dies in there i do the same [ __ ]
too beat you
a frog that's a giraffe went to the
san diego zoo you should have just got
got a cup and done him
took them outside oh stephen it was way
too
like we literally couldn't reach to
touch them with their own what about a
broom there's a [ __ ] frog
because it's once you hit it and it
falls yeah i'm not doing that is what i
miss about old
vacuum cleaners that have the bag that
you can throw away because this one you
have to deal with the body being there
yeah oh i always check the tube after
easily be a mom
and then could have more be i don't know
we just vacuumed it and we're just like
remember that video where they smooshed
the spider and thousands came out
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] that bro i don't do
it because i'm with poison
every time i want them to kill what i
got i can't kill spiders because my
sister would always be very sad if i
killed them
so i have it in my brain like what what
does it matter
well that's why i didn't want to kill it
i don't want to lose my situation
chances of getting with her
no but so i would always i would always
have to take them outside so i still do
that to this day i just can't kill a
[ __ ] spider because i think about my
sister
about how hot she is i let them all
exist and once a week
i turn on my fly killer thing and all
the bugs
they see the light and then they all die
i bought one of those and it doesn't
work where'd you put it in my kitchen
for a long time
the yeah the led light thingy or not
illegal
are there bugs in your kitchen um no but
like there would be flies and [ __ ] and
i'm like
die it works perfectly for me did you
have other lights on they're just going
to
you got to turn off all the lights
everything was dark it was only that
blue
bright ass like it's so [ __ ] bright
and it goes
yeah yeah it's like a pop rock pow or
get the tennis racquet with it
have you seen those i kind of want to
buy one of those those are cool get the
salt gun
my mom got one what's that you know the
salt blaster gun
yeah it's like it looks like a shotgun
and it shoots little like amounts of
salt at the flies
really yeah but then you get salt all
over your house yeah yeah
yeah salt everywhere what a waste of
salt you can like vacuum it up you get a
cucumber and dip it
make margaritas you look at the videos
though it looks cool
that's messy i don't know i do oh i i
think that's
fun so yeah i just have a pellet gun and
nice to kill the flies with the pellet
gun
because you don't even need to put
anything in there just the air blast
alone
so if i had like a uh yeah if i had like
a fly like on like my windows or my
blinds i just [ __ ] it once
and i go pop and then it's just fly guts
all over the
glass wow i need to try that no it's
you don't even need anything just goes
pop it just smears it that's dope
it's so strong very cool dude i
instantly got like an image of us like
50 years from now and people are like
can you believe they used to
kill insects oh yeah yeah oh my god
there were savages back then
and you call them [ __ ] they'd be like
i guess the guy with the hat was kind of
nice of the spider but he likes his
sister too much for me
or in 50 years they're like he got the
right idea but everyone but everyone's
like but you know how pretty she is
oh [ __ ] he was fashion forward we took
over
[Music]
you